OS chroma was like I want to get mr.
Gallup on the phone this is Chris Cuomo
well first off there is no mr. Gallup
and second you're naked I don't know if
this is another what I do
hmm well then I guess I'll take mr.
Quinnipiac put your way Chris yeah
that's a good idea the polls here
because everyone has been talking about
this and and I think listen polls matter
you can't be someone who entirely
discounts them but the methodology
matters as well
and I think we and we'll come back to
this polls are just as much or they have
morphed into just as much a tool to try
and shape public opinion as much as
they're supposed to be sort of a
temperature gauge public opinion but
this is the newest CNN poll let them say
it is this translating into support for
his opponent in November Jill Biden it
overwhelmingly is take a look at this
matchup that we have that's just it's
unbelievable to me
55 we're seeing a voiceover bipolar vote
for the president and that is so
important because it means that Biden's
over 50% I went when team from this
point onward Hillary Clinton never
reached this level she never got there
she never got above 50% so this means
especially looking at the other polling
that the president will have to take
back some abide in supporters if in fact
he wants to win okay either first shave
your chest or wear a tie
there's something very disturbing about
that chest hair with a Malia when you
look at the poll they shouldn't have
been silly and this is a perfect example
of the ego in chat Trump the Trump
campaign sent a cease and desist letter
to CNN which of course they've ignored
but and I don't say that he shouldn't
send a cease and desist because it's
inaccurate
right I just don't think it looks good
yeah but let's look at the actual
methodology the pull so it may come as
no surprise that the source of the poll
are the worst polls that they're
discussing there for Donald Trump is
CNN yeah that's the actual source for
the bull and if you're taking to the
methodology again for people who though
this looks really bad I'm Hillary
Clinton Oaxaca never taking different
sample sizes only 25% were Republicans
32% Democrats and 44% independents and
what really matters there is whoever is
conducting the poll that high number of
independents you can really stack that
that oh yeah you can but you could
handpick independence let's look at how
CNN is framing their own poll okay a
couple of things here but um this is
where they say that there has been
overwhelming support for the protest but
see the catch this is one of the first
sort of measures of whether or not
people are agreeing with these protests
or not and what we see is that they
overwhelmingly are agreeing with the
protest 84 percent say that they are
justify these peaceful protests okay 83
percent said that these these peaceful
vid the word peaceful was slipped in
there 84 percent of people support
peaceful protests what about what about
violent protests right did we ask them
yeah the number drops to 27% oh and keep
in mind that's with a sample draw of 75
percent non Republican voters and this
is something to think is very important
because first off we've showed how the
the sampling didn't talk about peaceful
protests can you name me any major city
where over the course of these two weeks
any major city I'm not talking about 20
people down in a suburb any major city
where once the lights went out the
protest didn't result in any violence
and even when I say that I'm not saying
any protests where there wasn't 25
million dollars in property damage like
I saw in Minneapolis long let's just
compare it to the Tea Party meaning zero
crime that's the standard zero cleaner
than when they got there any big city
where that's been the case in the last
two weeks you can't name one no again
there have been isolated protests small
and I want to be in the second riddle
today and then the lights go down and
the tear gas comes out and by the way it
should be a hundred percent of Americans
okay with peaceful protests yes that's
part of one of the rights that we have
we can protest injustice peacefully I
would answer everybody should be fine I
would answer yes if the question was
peaceful program or the other third
Dean or whatever percent it was fascist
Peas that's pretty important there's a
difference between polling people on
what they think of a personality versus
specific policies right so let's go to
some specific policies because they talk
about Donald Trump now he's not polling
very well and any given area but the
poll is really what do you think of
Donald Trump on blank well when you go
to specific policies and I think this is
important because 71% of Americans we've
talked about this they support using the
National Guard to address protests and
demonstrations that's seventy one
percent so that's different from how do
you feel about peaceful protests
fifty-eight percent supported sending in
the actual military right fifty-eight
percent supported seventy one percent
support using the National Guard which
candidates support the National Guard
which candidate excoriated the president
for wanting to send in the National
Guard there's only one person who's had
the balls to say all right we're gonna
sit in the National Guard and that's
going against the green with everyone in
the median entertain ministry so it's
important to keep that in context now I
say this because that was pointed to as
the most as extreme right-wing right
radical right-wing extremists fascism
they want to send in the National Guard
seventy one percent of Americans not
saying that polling makes something
morally justified in this case
constitutionally I believe it's morally
justified to protect the rights of
citizens it's legal that being said
seventy one percent of Americans support
it now let's contrast that that's
radical right-wing extremism senator
National Guard with radical left-wing
extremism defunding the police and
renaming streets and buildings no no no
the public outcry over George Floyd's
death has ignited debate and action on
police reform and a lot of people
advocating for what they have taken to
calling defunding the police the phrase
even appears in large yellow letters on
the newly named black lives matter plaza
on 16th Street near the White House
we're talking about police defunding the
police wildly unpopular only sixteen
percent of Americans support defunding
the police while sixty-five percent
oppose it 19 percent are unsure I guess
those are the the soundcloud rappers but
again this is so remarkable because some
people say well you're misrepresenting
it
on the police that just that just means
defunding it to a degree some people
believe that but that's not what is
being demanded by black lives matter you
have the mayor of Minneapolis who
checked his privilege and recognize his
own brokenness as a white person be
drummed out of the Corps by thousands of
people for saying that he didn't support
the outright abolition of police that is
not a minority opinion that's the
Minneapolis City Council opinion let's
be clear so even if you're saying well
that poll might be might potato sixty
five percent opposed it only sixteen
percent of Americans support that policy
so this is why this is important to me
when they constantly say we this radical
extreme right wing right wing on YouTube
right people going on a radical rabbit
hole let's take the furthest right
opinion as it was presented sending in
the National Guard how dare you this is
fascism seventy one percent of Americans
don't see it that way they support it
then let's take the furthest left
opinion that we can have right now in
this current concept defunding the
police sixty-five percent opposed to it
so I asked you which wing as represented
officially by the heads of their party
is more radical there are several
reasons by the way that pollsters have
gotten things wrong absolutely marijuana
use to be trust silver trust nate silver
now it's just like that's the [ __ ]
that's the stick that's his website
subtext it has a lot to do with how the
media covers donald donald trump there's
something called a social social
desirability bias then i'm gonna get a
little bit wonky but i'll try and keep
it short because i know that you you
know we are in pink hairdos social
desirability bias kay it's the tendency
of respondents in polls or surveys they
lie about their actual beliefs sometimes
because they want to answer in a way
that they view is more socially
acceptable okay so as it relates to
voting this social desirability bias i'm
saying this what you know what it is if
you haven't been to college you probably
hear about it there it created something
called the bradley effect okay named
after tom bradley he was a black
candidate lost in the 80s in california
was a gubernatorial race despite the
fact that he was leading in the polls
but people didn't want to be perceived
as racist as vote for that guy and then
they went back homeless are you voting
for that guy now
we use told him that you're gonna vote
for that guy yes because I was a black
panther with a baton so um they said
they were gonna vote for him because
even though they weren't going to vote
for him right and then there have been
case studies in this now let's for
context take a look at the way the media
is actually covered president Trump most
presidents would use a crisis like that
as an opportunity to bring the country
together and to denounce hatred but not
this president over the last 12 months
Trump has instead amplified his racist
rhetoric and policies about the
president the president is a racist as a
matter of fact I've known that the
president is a dangerous human being a
would-be dictator who would move in the
direction that he's doing president
Trump today denying that his racist
tweets were racist today it is the
United States of America the former
beacon of the free world that is the
subject of global revulsion and disgust
because of the raw ugly racism and
ethno-nationalism of our president and
by the way every single source is the
previous clip clip B knew for a long
time Donald Trump could be a racist and
dangerous man okay now we understand so
the principal again not wanting people
we talk about the Bradley effect to
perceive you as racist well how do you
think people are going to respond when
the media consistently says if you
support Donald Trump you're a racist
racist racist racist the MOG assemble
the okay simple which is by the way
don't tell home alone - it's on the
cover - for crying out loud this is
racist this is white supremacy if you
vote for Donald Trump it's white
supremacy check your priveledge voting
for Donald Trump is white privilege and
what you probably will want to avoid
being perceived as racist and so that's
another reason that the polls can't be
relied upon not always but specifically
we've seen historically with Donald
Trump another thing it isn't measured by
polls were little Michael Nelson just
two seconds here there's simple approval
and disapproval right and it glosses
over enthusiasm and I know the lot of
you little do the other doesn't matter
because people are they going to vote or
they're not now actually it's a more
significant determiner in who actually
gets out
votes on Election Day and that's the
reason there's this huge discrepancy
between likely voters and then actual
voters news polls are likely voters and
specifically is really from from Al Gore
onward outside of Barack Obama you can
think of Al Gore you can think of John
Kerry with John Edwards then you can
think of Hillary Clinton of course there
really has been an enthusiasm problem on
the Left so Hillary Clinton right she
led significantly among likely voters
but then trailed with actual voters now
recent polls they show that among
registered voters who support Trump 55%
of them are very enthusiastic about
backing him for Biden it's about it's
half that 28% are very enthusiastic and
I tell you what those 28% are committed
to the lie yeah exactly well and just to
go to your point when they say I really
know I'm going to enthusiastically both
Biden's like you show up in your eyes a
little bit I swallowed it back you got
me that they'll probably forget just
like Joe Biden will he'll forget he's
running for president I left in the
scene of hope goes back to your point
70% of the people that said that they
were voting for Trump they said it's
because I want Trump to win 60% of the
people voting for Biden didn't say it
because they liked Biden they said it's
they were voting against Trump right
right so that's not enthusiasm for your
candidate that's just being pissed off
in a moment that can change drastically
ya know that's a good point we'll wrap
this up with I think it's important
again the most important takeaway from
this poll is a CNN is not a news
organization okay be like they would
have been better off they would have had
more cover if they didn't release this
poll it's even just the fact 75% non
Republican respondents on Allen let's
just just remember CNN look searched
high and low and ask every pollster they
could can anyone come up with these
numbers no all right let's make our own
yeah nobody Louis chromo was like I want
to get mr. Gallup on the phone this is
Chris Cuomo
well first off there is no mr. Gallup
and second you're naked I don't know if
this is another what I do hmm well then
I guess I'll take mr. Quinnipiac
put your way Chris yeah that's a good
idea so number one CNN is not a news
organization two there's a huge between
polling people on personality traits
like how do you think Donald Trump
presents the country do you think Donald
Trump is right versus specific policies
should we send in the National Guard
should we defund the police those are
the polls that you should be looking at
to get a more accurate gauge at this
point and still taking into account that
there is a huge handicap seventy-five
percent non Republican responders with
CNN and the most important takeaway here
is this shouldn't affect your your
voting pattern or your canvassing
patterns at all you still need to go out
you still need to change people's minds
that's what changed my mind right didn't
exist before the last election that's
what it's for it's to walk people down
the path of rationalizing their own
argument there are far more people as
you see with these individual policy
polls who are more conservative than
they realize so all of you have a job to
do that don't think well because there's
high enthusiasm Donald Trump's going to
win anyway assume that he won't assume
the worst and work for the best know
that these polls that are every time one
of these polls comes out they are used
to try and manipulate the American
public perception of elections just as
much as they used to be used to try and
gauge where the election is actually
going that's not the case anymore polls
are a political tool at this point be
aware of it and do your part well guess
who I am
I'm Josh Hartnett bet you didn't think
you'd see that face in awhile as is what
we call an end card which is where I
tell you that you should subscribe if
you like this video or click one of
these other videos that you may like hit
the notification bell of course join mug
club because that's what allows us to
continue doing these videos and just so
you know YouTube actually is creative
new policy where they might start
outright banning channels that are no
longer commercially viable which means
that this is merely a figment of your
imagination